european union leaders meet to discuss
the results of the EU elections over the
weekend and work out how they should
proceed in nominating the next president
of the european commission at an
informal dinner summit in brussels heads
of state and government will talk about
the outcome of the europe-wide polls and
what can be learned from the way
citizens cast their ballots early
results confirmed that the center-right
European People's Party grouping would
retain the most seats in the European
Parliament with the Socialists in second
position the far right and some far left
parties made significant gains
nationally but this would not impact
greatly on the composition of the
European Assembly while it's probably
too early to discuss candidates for the
top Commission post the leaders will
need to decide on the process leading up
to any nomination as laid out in the
lisbon treaty the treaty requires the
leaders to take into account the choice
of the voters the nominee who would have
a mandate for five years to lead the e
use executive arm would have to be
endorsed by a majority in the parliament
in a letter inviting the leaders to
dinner the President of the European
Council Herman Van Rompuy urged them to
reflect on the challenges ahead as they
make their choice the heads of state and
government are also likely to debate
developments in Ukraine which also held
pivotal elections over the weekend